my point is asking can you play as black
ah am i okay yeah all right all right
let's do rematch there you go you got
what you wanted if you want to play as
white you don't get that I'll give you
black tough you want black okay all
right French defense land are we gonna
have the winner are you my opponent has
a maybe they're like hey I'm sniffing
something out my opponent isn't my
opponent is sensing a weakness that I
have against the French or something
wait they're saying let me let me
employed the Fort Knox defense I saw
something faulty there okay what do you
do now I'm just playing this the other
day is about Queen here just castle mmm
i was playing this the other day how did
that turn out I think it turned out
pretty good let's go Queen oh look out
ah okay okay okay this is a typical idea
what my opponent just did is very
typical
I want to keep my bishop on this
diagonal I might want to do night here
looks a bit weird I'm back up why would
I want to have my bishop on this
diagonal because I still have an idea of
getting in this d5 break I don't know
how exciting it will be to be on this
diagonal I guess it's still pretty good
but it's going to make my opponent think
twice that's for sure about about what
about this c5 break follow that by
having my bishop on this dog and I'll
opposed to this one I make this advanced
more difficult to get in and I believe
now the idea is correct in that of c-4
for carew skis around the corner as well
as just controlling d5 look at these
guys either one can make use of d5 why
is my computer going crazy why does it
have to be the fan working overtime here
this is very taxing with my setup here
okay
how about be three then Bishop b2 it
looks like a plan let's do it oh I just
dropped upon no way no I didn't it's
poison pond it's a poison pond variation
Queen takes T is a known trap be very
aware of it Queen takes d4 is a trapper
ruski is my opponent going to fall for
it
okay times or even so castles is
probably mainline our theory or
something development because the
position can open up at any moment this
king could be in some big trouble what
else that's kind of the direction you
have to go or maybe another one is to
just eliminate the night at this point
what else
what's the plan what is the big bad plan
I've I opponent did not have any of my
tricky thoughts of yeah this is a known
track no it's not psychological tricks
going on here i think my opponents
listening gotta use every resource every
resource I trying to throw out a dud and
to be honest I thought Queen takes pawn
was gonna be winning a piece but it's
not i do have Bishop e2 ah man ok let's
go here maybe you have to focus on time
now that you dropped upon oh man I'm
gonna come at my opponent hard now real
hard is the Queen dead is she close to
dead come on Queen you know you're
running short on squares are you gonna
reside over here oh you want me to move
my knight take right here let's not get
made it on age to know let's hit the
clean get out of their queen she might
be close to trapped watch where you're
going Queen you watch yourself I can
maybe chop here Oh chopper Rooskies
maybe a5 a4 a5 now where are you gonna
go clean you must be scared you're
running short on squares haha she's
scared she is definitely a scared Queen
right now Bishop back oh man I can't be
easy
oh come on you could do it you could do
it you could do it chop here boom chop
here with check oh that might be pretty
good I have to fear night moves here and
stuff tonight boom boom I could defend
that though maybe I chased the clean
away and then do that or something why
can't it be easy what's the time dead
listening to oh man chop chop chop King
here Bishop checks and stuff the Kings
running scared get the Queen out of here
first she's she's such a bug what a bug
that Queen no get out of their queen ah
f4 g5f 4G 4G five fortunately there's a
little bit of a lag so if you're
listening first and foremost shame on
you and secondly and secondly once it
gets down to time scramble you're not
gonna be able to listen ah watch out 4G
4G for right around the corner g4
material plus the queen is officially
down on squares TKO chop the deadly g4
advance uh-oh time is even position is
uneven o Knight has to give himself up I
play here and insist that I take that
Queen I like that I might be more
accurate right
am i right tell me if I'm right on that
one
um give that a shot no the Queen goes
here just take the night what are you
thinking about stay tonight while you
try to get fancy why are you trying to
get fancy all of a sudden just win the
game would you quit it with your fancy
stuff Bishop takes I take the Queen
first ooh where is she going move my
knight where's the mate where is that me
let's just defend for a second for a
second the queen is once again running
short on squares isn't she she most
certainly is okay let's just move the
Queen has to go back to f5 clock is
a-tickin tick tick tick I have stuff on
G
still still there
ok
well my opponents started her rattling
off a bunch of moves that really quick
it's quick mover give a check fear the
worst we can def 60 clamp down on that
the King has to be scared oh it's
definitely scared isn't he check a risky
let's just play here no matter what
uh-oh it's crumbling check bishops crazy
bishops rooking infiltration pigs pigs
everywhere where the pigs 18 okay I
caught up on time hitting the night
tricky bishop right here hit a rook
defend upon back up nice and cozy right
there bishop pins this rook is hit a
hundred times a lot of times there no
time where's the mate one two three no
no no no no no no clock situation right
there oh okay oh man okay good game mr.
dark mist let's back up here let's flip
that board let's see about this Fort
Knox french defence give up the bishop
pair in exchange for getting control
over d5 I don't know if this is correct
but um but what I wanted to back up
again this was my main idea I want to
stay on this diagonal 95 does that how
else can you be treating this I think
whites is a definitely better here
mm-hmm
95 not you might need to do you might
need to get in c5 very soon so what you
might be needing to do is something like
Queen c7 if Bishop f4 Bishop d6 I think
trying to get in this advanced right
here as soon as possible is the way to
go so somehow try and get that in I
can't can't be sure of it okay
nightnight f6 is fine development with
tempo bishop their castles instead of
the night move okay I think this is
where things are a bit off how about
Queen c7 right now more pressure on this
night and then look into this c5 advance
I think this is the way to get in that
break successfully Queen c7 you're
hitting this three times I have to do
something about it and I think I think
it'd be Bishop f4 rookie one Bishop f4 i
think is maybe better with this is the
follow-up I think you have to get that
in it becomes timely so Knight b6 a step
in the wrong direction I did drop upon I
did not calculate that so what I could
be doing is just something like this and
then going forward that although it
there does seem to be compensation still
because I am fully developed but I'd
much rather still have that pond around
for the d5 break so maybe just rook d1
anyhow look into that the c5 break you
have to break it my d4 pawn in some way
and c5 is it okay we close out good game
mr. dark mist